it doesn't matter who i am what matters
is the plan
[Music]
no one cared who i was
until i put on their hand
[Music]
all right gotta do everything
again i don't even know if i
i don't even know if i remember
clearly oh my god okay here we are
at the balls everybody the ball game
easiest one
[Music]
go go go go go there's an opening damn
it
come on man come on pewdiepie you can do
it
[Music]
hey look at that
[Music]
okay great let's do all of that again
yes
yes
okay all right i remember this damn it
damn it and you have to go up
and then down super fast oh oh i did it
oh my god he's the best and there was
this [ __ ]
no no
stop stop
[Music]
you know what never
[Music]
you know
[Music]
ah there you go very nice
no ah suck on my toes
can you not can you not can you not do
that please
please
this part is easy honestly if you die
this [ __ ] you can
lick on my turtleneck go look at that
look at that boy
hey you want to follow me guess what you
can't
stupid this bit is super easy unless
you're a pathetic
little [ __ ] pathetic a little
degenerate son of a
easy this is easy is what i'm trying all
right you're gonna come here and i'm
gonna go
yes and then you can
everyone can suck on my toes everyone
please stand in line i forgot to bomb it
all right here we go come on you didn't
bomb all of it
here we go
[Music]
go go i [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
i'm playing on an ipad i'm a gaming
channel
guys
you know what i really like repetition
you know what i also really like
repetition you know what i really really
[Music]
all right here's the ball bet everyone
everyone loves the bull bit
the balls ruined my life go damn balls
come on balls show me what you got then
balls show me come on balls
come on balls is that all you got balls
oh my god can you suck on my toes i just
pretend i'm not as good as i am
for the sake of entertainment value look
at that look at this first try
first try i'm in my little submarine now
guys first try please subscribe
to pewdiepie oh god all right first try
everybody subscribe to pewdiepie for
more epic gaming channels
like this one look at that first try not
even i did it blindfolded
okay all right all right this is a
little tricky
if you're a [ __ ] look at this look at
this
skill i know i know what you're thinking
how is he
so great and good looking at the same
time
well you know it comes from
this bit can just look at it
look at it okay
[Music]
no i'm not gonna
look at that you can suck on my ninja
turtle
damn it now
pathetic disgusting snotty noise
pimple-faced
beta gamers that can't even beat a game
and get all angry pathetic truly
pathetic look at me do
this on the actually very first try all
the ball bits some people say the ball
bit is difficult
if you're a [ __ ] perhaps i could agree
look how
easy this is uh
oh no oh no oh oh oh
no can you edit it in so i do it on the
first try
here we go finally
[Music]
good job can you start moving right god
damn it
what are you doing
stop
what if you do that again i swear i'm
gonna get really angry
[Music]
come on here we go guys
let's freaking do this
[Music]
hello everybody at the gamer 69
here let's begin this video um
starting off right stop judging me
i'm not lying all right i'm starting now
welcome i just started playing this game
let's begin the gameplay wow this game
is so easy how could anyone possibly do
this game
you'd have to be a complete [ __ ]
[Music]
today
i bet you jacksepticeye could never beat
this game look at this
look at it look at it i'm gonna roll
baby i'm always on a roll
i've always sort of now edit that out
edit that out i'm on a roll baby
zero depths everybody this is incredible
never done
before look at that look at that i'm not
even a gaming channel anymore and i can
still
beat any game at any given point with
my superior skill
and superior handshakes
[Music]
look at that dude look at that my dudes
drop the bomb and go through
go yes oh
i have never made it this far
oh my god oh my god guys i have never
made it this far
oh my god guys can we hit a leave a like
on this video right now this is so
epic i need to actually blow my noise so
that doesn't happen again because that
was disgusting
[Applause]
where did he go when
will he return the prophecies states
that a time will come when i
the [ __ ] you say about me boy dude even
the music changed
how epic is this all right so this is
easy it's gonna be
the classic sliding bit where you slide
off the
the pad i'm not gonna slide off because
i'm not an idiot
oh my god this is so damn it stop
sliding
oh oh where the hell did the platform go
oh it melts
damn it come on
no
no
[Music]
stop
[Music]
stop killing me
i lost all the progress i have to do all
of that again
that's great that's great i'm happy for
you man i'm glad that's
oh look i level up everyone here we are
again mr iceman
so we meet again our battle begins jump
jump damn it our battle continues jump
jump don't go in
our battle continues my friend jump
jump our battle begins
can you get inside him
[Music]
come on it's not even hard
it's not even [ __ ] high dude
why do you go in there
positive attitude guys let's believe
press press like if you believe guys
just
you didn't believe hard enough don't you
feel ashamed
so we meet again mr eyes
damn it
no come on you can do this
come on feeler come on felix we believe
in you
i'm trying ah
crazy oh my god this game is so easy
ah the easy sliding technique
[Music]
great
[Music]
hey look at that first try everyone i am
practically a genius what is this
what is i'm serious what is this
how am i supposed to do here what the
hell is this
what do i do what do i do
i am inside him
what do i do guy oh oh my god i'm
supposed to shoot him die
damn it
[Music]
we're gonna
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
anyway guys hope you enjoyed this video
oh anyway guys honestly it means the
world to me if you would leave a like on
this video
perhaps share it with your friends show
your support for the gaming of this
channel
let's hashtag bring back pewdiepie
gaming
if you want more epic gaming montages
like this one make sure that you
watch another one and another one and
never stop
what else are you gonna do with your
life honestly you made it this far in
the pewdiepie video
honestly it's pathetic
anyway brofist